en una rueda de prensa ambas autoridades
han confirmado que 58 personas han sido
asesinadas e inclusive 12 heridos en un
nuevo amotinamiento específicamente en
la penitenciaría de guayaquil
específicamente esto se agrega a las 270
personas que han muerto en las cárceles
del país en lo que va de año según
cifras oficiales estos eventos ocurren
desde en la noche de este viernes y se
han trasladado hasta la madrugada de
este sábado ha sido hasta el día de hoy
cuando se ha emitido la información
oficial la cárcel de guayaquil tiene 12
pabellones y aproximadamente cada uno de
ellos tienen 700 internos y ha sido la
el control del territorio la causa de
estos eventos según la información de el
ejecutivo nacional específicamente
también se relaciona con que varios
líderes y algunos pabellones han
conseguido su libertad luego de haber
cumplido más del 60 por ciento de su
pena por el cual la policía nacional
mantiene un protocolo de seguridad desde
la noche del viernes pero hay otros
eventos también relacionados a estos
amotinamientos que suceden el día de hoy
por lo menos este viernes tres reos
intentaron ingresar un amplio arsenal
bélico por lo menos mil municiones y
fusiles de asalto y dinamita se ha dicho
por parte de la policía nacional
rompiendo así el cerco perimetral del
centro penitenciario y fueron detectados
y capturados para evitar el ingreso de
estas armas por lo menos desde hace una
semana tres bandas delictivas intentan
activar a sus integrantes en las calles
para dotarlos de armas y esto ha sido
detectado hace una semana por parte de
los cuerpos de seguridad pero finalmente
que está sucediendo esto sucede en medio
de un estado de excepción dentro de seis
días aproximadamente estaría concluyendo
un estado de sección que inclusive ha
reducido el tiempo del estado de sesión
de 60 a 30 días ha sacado también a los
cuerpos de l'or específicamente la
fuerza armada en nacional cuando la
corte de constitucional ha dicho que la
fuerza armada sólo pueden permanecer
fuera de los centros penitenciarios y
también se ha emitido un informe por
parte de la asamblea nacional donde se
ha dicho que el estado ha perdido el
control de los distintos centros
penitencia por lo menos de manera
progresiva en los últimos seis años
específicamente en diez cárceles de país
nueve tienen grandes en fallas de
seguridad y otras tienen fallas
estructurales dos tienen fallas
estructurales como falta de servicios
básicos e inclusive en algunos casos no
hay agua potable el servicio eléctrico
no alcanza la comida no hay suficientes
agentes de seguridad esto sucede cuando
existe un hacinamiento aproximado del
50% de todo el sistema carcelario en el
país gracias gustavo